hi i'm greg gutfeld with jesse waters
katy pavlich juan williams
and she once had to put down on my
little pony dana farino
the five
yesterday president biden signed four
executive actions based on racial equity
focusing on systemic racism in private
prisons
housing coveted relief and tribal
relations
apparently systemic racism is like
oxygen it's everywhere you look
and the solution is equity not equality
equity even joe's using the word does he
know what it means
who knows which means it's time for
greg explain stuff the media wishes
you wouldn't understand not crazy about
the hair
equality as you know means you have the
opportunity to try something even if
you're bad at it
i can try to play basketball i will suck
but in america
i have an opportunity to try just like i
have the opportunity to become an
electrical engineer
a pipe fitter or a peloton instructor
i would suck at those too but it's
against the law to discriminate against
me
it's about equality of opportunity not
equality of
outcome which is what equity promises
equality of outcome a reserved space
based on the single variable of systemic
discrimination
your equity becomes an entitlement so
even though i suck at basketball there
should be a place for me
in the nba equity not only ignores
competence
it reduces the diversity of talent that
comes from opportunity as well as
ignoring
how people choose different things shall
we create female quotas
for loggers and roofers and garbage
collectors and other male-dominated jobs
even if women don't want them you know
workplace death
for men is 10 times higher than women
do activists seek equity there or is it
just the cush
jobs they're after and of course with
equity you you will need someone to
decide who gets what
and that's what this is really about
power the power to remake society to
placate the critical race theorist
who works with only one variable revenge
it's about the furthest you can get from
unity not that joe would know
or care
[Music]
all right juan i hope you appreciated my
essay
my question to you is if equity is about
allocating resources
to create equal outcomes how is that
possible when every single person is
different you're going to need
laws quotas and force like you would
have seen in ussr during their communist
era
if you want everybody to equal you need
force
uh let me tell you how i see this greg
because it's really quite
different i mean to me to my mind let's
just look at it this way you know
if you look at where the cities in
america put incinerators where they put
dumps uh you know even when they build
highways it always goes through
minority neighborhoods poor
neighborhoods and the case the highways
cutting them off from downtown and much
of the economic activity of those
places you think about things like
government
assistance for housing mortgage
assistance after world war two
student aid programs after world war ii
overwhelmingly even
farm aid farm bureau programs
discriminated against black people
in this country's history so biden to my
mind greg it's not about
guaranteeing any individual outcome what
it's really saying is we need
to make sure that the starting point for
everyone
is level that we're on a level playing
field i mean this extends to childhood
poor where poor quality schools are
higher levels of
unemployment and scarcity of jobs
again to me this is really the problem
that joe biden is talking about when he
talks about equity making sure that
government
is playing fear for all people and you
know
to me it's it's a painful thing because
it's plain for me to see
in my life and i think it should be
plain for everybody to see
uh you know and i think when you talk
about like how police treat black people
and
stuff like that it just it burns and
hurts deeply when others say oh there's
nothing going on here and it's just so
plain for me to see
yeah i think the thing is though that
everything you just mentioned in the
front of that commentary i would
absolutely agree with you're talking
about everybody having equal opportunity
but equity builds into this idea of uh
up um outcome equality which is
absolutely impossible
it's impossible by the way that's what
he's talking about
that's that's exactly what equity is
defined as that's what makes it
different than equality
but anyway i agree with everything you
said that's what we all want and
discrimination is illegal
and it should be dana no matter how hard
you try to make it legal
so dana here's what this is a different
part of the equity equality thing that
drives me crazy is that we
uh we talk a lot about female equality
in certain jobs
but they never really talk about the
jobs like loggers
or those kind of jobs you always talk
about ceos and cfos and
football coaches but you never talk
about the the ones where
men are dying by you know the hundreds
or thousands every year
that's what you would call sweat equity
i believe those jobs you have a lot of
that
i was trying to remember do you remember
like about four months ago or so
there was a controversy that bru came up
and trump was involved in
merriam-webster's dictionary changed the
definition of the word
um in order to conform to what the
left wanted it to be and i feel like
this equality equity thing and i'm glad
thank you actually i feel like you've
done a public service for all of us to
explain
all of this because it's like wait where
did this word come from and did you
catch
joe biden today he was talking about
equity in his speech and then he said
equality and he's like
equity yeah because it's not natural the
one thing though that i didn't hear
anyone talk about today
from the white house is what's the main
issue that you can deal with to ensure
equality of opportunity
which will get you to more equity and
that is
education k-12 education and
to one's point one you're fortunate to
have had
a a mom and a the the drive that you had
the education you had and you have made
so much of yourself
and you're here with us and we're so
glad for that and i look at this across
the country and think k through 12
education
it is not up to speed especially after
the pandemic
but that's how you get to equality and
equity
the last thing i would say is if you
believe that america is an
exceptional nation as many people in
america believe
but also so many people around the world
they believe america is an exceptional
nation and why because at least in
america
you would have a shot everyone would
have a shot to try hard to work
if you come here and you have a dream
you have a business idea
you can make it here unlike in many
other places around the world most other
places around the world
mm-hmm and to your point about the
teachers that we're going to be talking
about that the b block the teachers
unions
are no help in this so jesse i wrote
this monologue because of you
i think it was you yesterday saying you
didn't know what equity was and you
didn't know why
it was being so i wrote that for you was
my instruction helpful
well juan made a very convincing case
greg but i think you made a better one
and here's why if you read biden's
speech
from yesterday in print what he says is
exactly what you said and it's very
slick
he says that all men are created equal
but because of
slavery and historical injustices
some of us are not equal therefore we
have to impose
equity we have to impose a
fair outcome in order to address
these historical problems and if you
disagree with any of that
then you're discriminating against
people and he puts susan rice
on point for this and he even spells out
who he's talking about
racial minorities religious minorities
indians and people that are in protected
classes
and he even spells out how he's going to
do it greg
he says housing is a right free housing
he says he wants to have universal pre-k
he says he wants certain people to have
access to certain
loans certain universities get special
perks
he says he wants to federalize the
voting system in this country
he wants to guarantee certain levels of
health care
so if you're looking at that that looks
like back backdoor socialism
and it kind of looks like to some people
like it's backdoor reparations
i don't think you can say that yet
because it hasn't been
implemented yet but the way it's so
vague
it leaves you to believe yeah i'm for
this i'm for that i want everyone to be
prosperous
but when you see that susan rice is in
charge
and she's picking winners and losers
with her lawyers and her bureaucrats
and she's going to destroy you if you
get in your way that doesn't sound very
unifying and the federal government is
so big so powerful
and has the arm of the department of
justice this affects hiring
this this affects firing this affects
buying selling contracts admissions
this affects everything so when you look
back and you see this might destroy the
dollar because it's going to
spend trillions of dollars why
are we doing this greg donald trump's
america first agenda lowered the black
poverty rate to the first time
under 20 percent had the black jobless
rate to the lowest level
ever exploded wages to the highest level
in 60 years
why wouldn't you want that capitalistic
approach
because they don't want capitalism they
want socialism they want them to be in
charge
and that's the problem it's not going to
work it's going to make them feel better
but it's not going to work so katie last
word to you what i think these the idea
of centrist
joe biden lasted all of 24 hours
because this is about as far from the
center as you can get
you you were warned greg the problem
with
conflating equity and equality of
opportunity is that equity
actually requires that you discriminate
against certain kinds of groups so we've
seen this in academia
with harvard getting sued for
discriminating against asian
students for example and i think that
you have to look at it in the broader
picture it's always
talked about in this narrow lens of race
but we've seen
the mayor of baltimore who is is black
the mayor of atlanta is black the mayor
of chicago is black
and for me when you look at it and break
it down by population and where these
problems
are happening it looks more like a
political class issue than it does
a race issue and there's no
accountability for the federal
government spending
trillions of dollars throughout the
decades on these issues
with no real return on investments and
then of course you have
the teachers unions not allowing for any
kind of school choice which just
enables this vicious cycle of poverty in
these places while the federal
government pretends that they're doing
something about it
that's a good point all right up next
the biden white house siding with the
teachers union
refusing to return to classrooms even
though the cdc
just said it was safe